I've dreamed about this since I was a
little kid and now that it's all
happening so fast I'm only 16 and it's
it's crazy asher angel electrifies the
silver screen in Shazam okay
Shazam crazy cereal it's it's my money
it's with fulfillment et spoke with the
actor at the movies la première where he
praised his co-star Shazam himself
Zachary Levi I was a fan before we even
started all of this madness and he's
like our big brother and he's such a
genuine guy and he's like our mentor and
we love him and you know I've learned so
much from him and he's just like my big
older brother and he's the best he's
everything I'd want to be when I'm older
so for sure
in this movie Shazam is the word of
choice but for Asher he's got another in
mind I probably go something random like
a random word like electric car or like
something like that and that's your car
I'm just grateful to be alive and
employed alive and employed but not just
with any old gig Zachary Levi is Shazam
I've actually kind of run out of words I
don't know it's very out-of-body it's
very humbling I've been doing this for
20 years now I've come to so many
incredible premieres doing this and I've
always kind of I don't know dream that I
would that I would be that guy and now
I'm that guy and it's very very very
weird but I'm incredibly grateful you
know I'm just and just trying to take it
all in and enjoy it as best I can and
just so excited for these young kids
Asher and Jack and just all the kids in
the movie and their rise their talent
like it's just it's so cool
Zachary also poked fun at seeing his
face all over town posters billboards
bus stops you name it yeah it's a little
abrasive actually like I'm so
unbelievably impressed by Warner
Brothers and new lines promotional
campaign like I am everywhere to the
point where I feel like I have to
apologize to people like I'm Sol I go
I'm sorry like it was one thing when I
was in a lot of places and now it's like
people can't go buy a bus stop without
being like there's actual bubblegum
again so I apologize anyone that this is
becoming ridiculous
- I'd like to purchase some of your
finest beer please and the question on
everyone's mind
what about Shazam the sequel you know
what I I hope so
I hope so I hope we get to do this as
long as we're allowed to do this we got
to wait for this movie to you know open
and see how it does I hope everyone out
there goes and sees it I promise you I
promise you it's fun I promise you it's
full of joy you will walk out of the
theater floating a foot off the ground
and feeling like a kid again
yeah you will electrocute a bus and
almost kill these people and then I got
it